what year did you do a Few Good Men on
Broadway
that was uh technically my second
Broadway show the first one was a little
flop Musical and I joined the cast of A
Few Good Men they've been running for
several months and I uh I got hired to
be the new understudy for the colonel
and the doctor which is a character
who's not in the movie so people won't
know who that is now this is before the
movie right well before the movie it was
I mean Aaron Sorkin was just some kid
from Scarsdale who got lucky and had a
play on Broadway and you know I mean not
lucky happened to be a genius writer but
you know nobody knew who he was uh and
uh and you know aside from the the
couple of movie and TV actors that they
had headlining both the original and
then and then The Replacements when I
when I uh joined it was Brad Whitford in
the Tom Cruise role wow um
and uh you know the the rest of the cast
uh Ron Perlman was playing the colonel
that uh whom I understudied the rest of
the cast were you know relatively
unknown New York theater guys you know I
is this is this true that Aaron Sorkin
heard that you were going up because you
were the understudy and that you were
going on
to play Colonel Jessup and he raced to
the theater when he heard you were going
on
and he was just to this day said he was
blown away by this powerful performance
and and is it one of your favorite
performances that you've done in your
career that you can recall it absolutely
is
um honestly if I had to choose
the one
moment that that uh that was the most
profound and meaningful to me uh as an
actor it was it was
those four or five uh performances that
I got to go on for Ron who was
incredibly generous and and and Brad and
and the whole rest of the cast who were
so welcoming and opening and wonderful
and then and then yeah the highlight of
that being that
that Aaron came uh to see the show and I
don't recall if it was my my first
performance I guess it probably was
um
and uh
and he uh uh that interaction is is is
one of the the
the most fulfilling
uh moments of of my career as an actor
because I I
his acknowledgment that I had fulfilled
what he put on the page was was uh you
know
all I've ever strived for as an actor
all I want
this is how selfish I am and childlike
is I'm I'm first of all I'm upset that I
couldn't I didn't see that performance
because knowing you in movies like
Whiplash and and shows Oz and all these
Great Performances you've done I I can
only imagine you saying you can't handle
the truth and God would I pay for you to
be that intense get back to that moment
from 32 years ago and just say you can't
handle the truth I I would die to see
that did you do you think when you
watched Jack Nicholson do it did you
think I was right up there with him
it was I I'll be 100 honest those of us
who did the play
saw the movie
as wonderful as it was uh and and we're
like
the play was better
um wow in in in in many ways and and uh
you know look I'm not gonna say you know
that's the beauty of a part of the
beauty of what we do I mean people like
to hand out trophies and awards for the
best actor and the best this and that
but you know the reality is it's about
his apples and oranges as as you can be
Jack Nicholson you know when I played
that part I was 35 years old that was
what the character was that Aaron wrote
in the play right right he was not a fat
cat who was uh you know sitting on his
throne I don't know how old Jack was
when he did it but he was you know the
character
because he was the guy playing it I mean
because he was the guy playing it he was
it was brilliant but it was a different
character too because he was an older
guy
the character has written is a guy who's
he's on his way to the White House you
know or he's at the very least going to
be Secretary of Defense right or you
know a senator I mean he he's he's a guy
who's who's on his way somewhere not a
guy who's you know who settled in to to
this is you know I'm the king of this
domain and that's it so that to me was
the fundamental difference uh between
between those characters
how do those versions of that character